good morning John and Alex this is one
of 10 drive-through testing sites at
Walmart locations all across the state
and testing here is performed on Mondays
Wednesdays and Fridays back here
employees are out here setting up tents
getting ready for the first round of
patients which are already here and
testing here starts at 7:00 a.m. and a
partnership between Walmart quest
agnostics and state and local leaders
testing here is for adults who meet CDC
and state guidelines and those in
high-risk groups who may not show
symptoms the goal is to get more people
tested so that doctors get a better idea
of who has the virus and how it is
spread they also want to identify hot
spots early according to the Institute
for Health metrics and evaluation Nevada
is behind the national average when it
comes to tests per capita governor steve
says alike has said we must perform more
daily tests before big businesses like
bars and casinos are allowed to reopen
and to make an appointment you'll have
to head over to the Internet
Mike West covetous dot-com and tests are
free for all adults and according to
Walmart quest agnostics will deliver the
test results within two days reporting
live this morning Hector Mejia 8 news
now